vaise tumhe yaadein aaj kya hai?
Aaj ka din kaise bol sakta hoon?
Badkismati se aaj ka din tumse meri shaadi ho gayi thi.
tum bhi na, mazak karna kab chhodoge?
chalo main afis ke lie late ho raha hoon.
Are sab, kaisi rahi hai goa ki trip?
kaun gaya goa?
पिछले हफ़ते तो आप गये थे?
pagal hai kya? kuchh bhi bole ja raha hai.
अरे, आ गया आप?
pata nahin kart ko kya ho gaya?
Kah raha hai pichhle hafte main Goa gaya tha.
Main kaisi cheezein bol sakte hoon?
lekin gaye to te aap.
tum bhi pagal ho gai ho kya?
Are yaar, bata nahin sab pagal ho gaye hain.
Kah raha hai ham pichle hafte goa gaya tha.
Tu pichhle hafte goa gaya tha?
Tu bhi pagal ho gaya hai kya?
aar gae to hamen badalaav lena pada